Today's new member of the day, Patricia Francis.
Patricia, I really appreciate your support
or kind of stumped Patricia Francis. I hope
I'm saying that right. Uh, really appreciate
your support, Patricia. Uh, supporting us
with a membership@davidpakman.com slash membership.
Also want to say thanks to today's long time
sustaining member of the day and that is our
most of Fargo who has been with us for nearly
five years. A very, very long time. More than
one presidential term or the equivalent of
about 93 Trump White House communications
directors is what that works out to very long
period of time. But thanks to both of you,
join them@wwwdotjoinpacman.com 40% off coupon
code available. This is 2020. The code, this
is 2020 saves you 40% off of the membership
of your choice. Okay. There is a place where
you can discuss a newsworthy items discussed
on the program and those not covered on the
program with other David Pakman show viewers.
Nearly 10,000 people are now subscribed to
the David Pakman show, sub Reddit, which you
can find@davidpakman.com slash r e d d. I.
T. We didn't cover this story but it was mentioned
on the subreddit, so I'll bring it up now.
There was a very strange development where
this Trump troll Jacob Wall who was previously
wrapped up in trying to generate false sexual
assault claims against Robert Mueller has
been caught trying to concoct bogus sexual
assault claims against Pete booted, judge
and um, the first comment or their ass, why
won't this dude go away? Meaning Jacob Wall.
And I completely concur with that sentiment.
And more importantly, is he ever going to
face consequences and actually have to maybe
go to prison or jail for the stuff that he's
doing because there is a significant amount
of, um, uh, extraordinarily improper behavior
here, some of which may actually rise to the
level of criminality.
And of course, tainted in all of this. Like
Pete Budaj edge is a gay guy and wrapped up
in trying to concoct sexual assault allegations
against him. Is this a implicit smear that
is often levied by the homophobic right against
gay men of them being pedophiles or assaulters
when in reality they're, they're just attracted
to men that that's it. Um, and Jacob Wall
a diving headfirst into that. So notable story,
uh, want to acknowledge it, although we're
not going to be covering it in to too much
detail on the show. Also from the David Pakman
show, sub Reddit, I spotted a post in response
to my live stream. Would Steven Destiny Banal
from a couple of days ago asking, can we get
David and destiny drums keyboard single during
their next show together? Yeah. So people
notice that last week when I was PR broadcasting
remotely, I had an electronic drum set behind
me and destiny during our livestream had a
keyboard, piano, a digital piano, electronic
piano.
I don't know what they're called at this point
behind him. And what about the idea of us
doing some kind of musical collaboration?
And I'm game. If people want to contact destiny
and tell them that we should do this, I'm
glad to do it. It could be done live. I mean
we could say eff it. We'll do it live. I'll
just, I'll write it and we'll do it live.
That's one possibility. The other possibility
is that we record our parts separately and
or something like that, but I'm completely
up for a music collaboration with destiny.
Join the discussion has nearly 10,000 of you
already have David pakman.com/r. E. D. D I.
T.